it's this one it's gone leave a thing
like that it just comes out with tape we don't have to be there is
ground or just i just know what they say they say they
say to
and for whom it will work is for them the
truth the bow and make the stains i
don't have it but i just asked him who  no
one got hurt what else with me there
leave me like that soon after see
that they took me both are mine isn't it
Stayed when I think it's better or
yesterday you Viseu to Jehovah stays in everything and
when it takes how good it is like this  it's
hard to walk in this universe It can
be opened here with the other is what we are it
's cute if it doesn't work I'll post
design Web Design so there's this one here
SP that was one
And then there's a descendant That's right
Sofia listening took her where she  there your
family who is a partner then moving
governor Alckmin like this like this I
know Renault Law School Since then I
had to find High is that sai has the alcinha
ground was the collaboration with created
design banners such a praise slime stayed
tell me the truth and if  enroll  er Clean
and Clean with your grandmother told Store
Sweet Confeitaria Doce at Quinta do
Careca
[Music]
a miracle doors to follow that stayed as
soon as the sun goes down and you have to hit
it by hand designer today Studio 8 in 8
minutes moving your butt go  old mobile
in Google was the language of life mine
Look at friendship control here it's cute is
more Google Buzz is
[Music]